let's talk about when the low and you
know she had this show on own which is
Oprah's network that nobody knows what
channel it's on it's appropriate
apparently
and the show got cancelled needed one
season it just got camp that had poor
rating surprise surprise
and there's a lot of drama around the
show now I actually hadn't watched
the show until we decide to do things
like caught up a little bit
show your book clip about Lindsay show I
may have been sections two certainties
life but a nice enjoy your typical
addict it's not going and what not
campers who I know the difference in my
long and stupid in the etiology can you
know what's going bad like to know that
was raised well what evidence but
thats unit the
that there's certain things that people
don't know what is around people
sometimes but I see that now
you the buying
we don't usually do this kinda stuff on
the show but I thought this was
particularly
thing because it's related to Oprah and
how much truth there we get mad at her
and lindsey is just that a trainer
so first just well let's just talk about
the train wreck part of it
I am why are we obsessed with train
wrecks why
wide no matter with Justin Bieber peas
in a slut bucket you know the bill
clinton
and you know amanda Bynes towards buying
at a window was my bond which is
that the upsetting part it's like why
worry it s these people
well that uses liver is climb very high
and you let him fall I'm inspired the
kind of story we've been conditioned to
expect
and so when someone is that they miss
and that popular and that a rich you
kind of expect this
thus downfall aspect to happen that's
like that with the story ends
yeah from I think legit around for so
long we've seen ups and downs
down I personally watched the show
hoping you would be
I mean I'm or those people who actually
wants her sexy so you thought that
somehow she was gonna be
get her Mayakoba through this well I
don't know what I thought
but I kept watching so Eimear its
its top I mean she really is actually
she's trying to push is also very
diluted and so you can see that in the
show
yeah um now what channel is it by the
way I have no idea you don't even know
Nuby
I DVR'd I don't hey I don't know already
the DVR now's
yeah what it what do you think what's
the train wreck explanation because
there's something deep
in the human psyche that love why I
think part of it is actually in
just did addition to narrative and the
fact that when someone reaches the top
thats if it was a movie that be the end
of the narrative
but in life it continues to go on so we
seek out
the next part of the story we want to
see the next part of the story
and I think this is a
you know kind of %uh the Heisenberg
uncertainty principle it's like
something that is watched will be
changed
and when you start pointing a camera and
burn paparazzi around
these people at all times like
that will drive someone crazy and I
think we've seen that with so many
people though it's
it I mean TMZ I have plays this
triste whenever somebody gets into
serious trouble and something really bad
happens
teams he suddenly seems like really like
and respect for out rather like Syrian
really are praying for include you were
a big part of what happened to you this
is a
someone who maybe didn't like shoot
someone but provided the gun
their I know he's evolved step over hope
they are you personally affected their
views of something great to put some
that powder alcohol in now with
happy with the help of them from TMZ
yeah 11 more Harvey Levin put it in his
little young sucking on that then
constantly
amid this remind me a little bit that
South Park
episode with you know that humans we
step human sacrifice and now
we're not sacrificing these people to
death but we're we're just putting them
up there
that I get that sorta goes to what
you're saying about it there's like this
deep need in a
is really dark zeiger yet not as dark as
the show Lindsay
the yeppers I feel darker than let you
set up to the part that may be really
want to talk about this though with the
Oprah connection because you're
everything Oprah is built herself on has
been actually what we think OVR the
reverse
Lindsay Lohan and everyone was like oh
she's gonna give her a chance and Oprah
configuring the OAG up because oprah can
do anything but
even Oprah now the chief a lot better
than
I don't know about face a very sad the
whole show I'm still reeling
yeah it's been a it's been a it up
several weeks but I'll I i think that
I don't know it's hard because with hope
for you you kind of wonder she come into
this with the intentions you know what
she
actually trying to help someone that is
that is her per feign
so we believe that our thing but she
also wants to make money right you want
somebody to watch The Cherry Orchard
doesn't work so I think it's a mix look
up for he should love Tyler Perry
programming is doing pretty well
do we have a laugh track and someone put
a real and rather put on your show here
you're laughing but it's doing really
well via I'll mmm
people love to people love Tyler Perry
I'll in the not so much but I i think
that
it's a combination of one in the ratings
also believing that I think she budget
craft a story where
it is this addict who has failed so many
times before but now she suddenly
it's a come to Jesus moment and Oprah is
Jesus and that's like that so that's the
show but that was isn't happening has
landed on the predictable and you can't
kinda
force in attic into that that narrative
yeah
so that's the part that I think that you
think this is if that's the case let's
people over all the credit what she
really did issue a helpful in the
you know all that well then she sorta
failed in her mission right
sure I i mean ship ok
anything what she did 13 with Jeff when
Sardar
she was a James pride she let him know
that a
but I I die I think the problem is also
lindsey's you know who knows what her
addiction and her real
situation is but there seems to be a
component that we're fame
is enabling the worst aspects over
addictions
and well I watched some love the show
and its
seem to me that this was not
a that the way if you really wanted to
help when the low and the way to help
her was not to put her exact find it
like to take what's been driving her
crazy
and then just blow it out times a
million
it would be to remove her from the
spotlight and
right isn't that something that sort of
perverse I mean Oprah must have thought
about your gonna take like a
pay my dick did person right and she
prided its money things to which he
sorta said she was or wasn't wasn't
really care that
and then you're gonna give them more on
that leg isn't that a little
just about devils advocate there is an
avid accountability to it
and I think that i watch Real Housewives
still Beverly Hills
them camera with Adam India yeah I don't
want to tell a pair not right now I
don't
edges and I know that exist um Kim
Richards recovering alcoholic
said the show basically saved her life
because she was being filmed all the
time
she could secretly drink she couldn't
avoid people calling are now calling on
camera
yeah I made her get treatment I left the
normal course of action for an addict
I'm just saying
there is a their his an aspect
accountability when you're telling
someone
Bravo an hour truly the greatest man
alive I'll be attics
yes Ike on Bravo added to that list what
are you doing whatever sorry all gone
yeah 'em what do you guys do how do you
personally deal with the train wreck
people cuz like amanda Bynes when she
was going off the rails and and beer and
all that like
I follow them on Twitter just really
purely for the jokes
but every now and again I do start like
when amanda Bynes was really
going down the tubes I started feeling
bad I was like I'm not gonna joke about
any workers
she literally could you show up in a
gutter and then I'll I guess I'll feel
bad
how do you could you want to be part is
I guys right we're all in it
and I I think there's a difference
between
someone like Justin Bieber who I know it
doesn't seem
like there's an addiction and it doesn't
seem like there's it seems like he's
kinda vay
smart ass kid and he does asshole things
run a grand scale of it oh yeah i mean
he he was is
basically Dennis the Menace with like a
lot of money and accountability yeah
where is Lindsay Lohan and and amanda
Bynes there seems to be some
some actual medical mental but possibly
a issues at play and that
there's a difference between it feels
darker and
meaner and it's the same way when people
joke about you know like Miley Cyrus is
in the hospital recently for like a real
like shit bad
reaction to penicillin or something up
but the the jokes immediately about you
know
well what would be the best team teaser
Road she's pregnant with so and so does
into
and it just becomes you know but if
something truly terrible happens to
those pursuing
so how do you have an email address I
mean there's you have to cut back a lot
things and you know it's like how much
of a dick is that person
so with Justin Bieber like he is a he is
a day like that we don't feel guilty for
making
I love him right I'm with someone who's
going struggling and you have to look at
and say like
can I make a joke and limit myself after
doing so i think that
I hold back a lot of people because I'd
don't back it kinda cope with it
very calm and then everyone smother
someone like Bieber is a great example
who just
I mean where there's no sympathy for him
like we're not worried about him
if he were clearly struggling maybe I
would step back but right now he's just
be in just 10 he's just a rich and that
spoiled rich kid
is a is this is a problem but it's not
like gasoline you can
you can treat medically cell are more
integrated
yeah yeah but it would help to fix him
to give it to him but I don't think it's
gonna happen
yeah very well said Bieber you're
welcome to come on the show a time and
defend yourself
we'd love to have you